when you run a command like cat from the
terminal it just works but when you try
to run dog it says command not found
that's because your file system is like
a big maze the path environment variable
is like a map that tells your computer
where to find the binaries that actually
execute these commands in Linux print
the path by putting a dollar sign in
front of it notice how it contains a
bunch of directories separated by colons
when you enter a command the computer
will search through these directories
then run the first binary it finds with
a matching name if the command is not
found you may need to update your path
by concatenating a new directory to it
like so